Nobody listens to French music anymore.
We had Edith Piaf,
Serge Gainsbourg,
the two robots and that
small boy in a big hat.
Now the kids want Cardi B,
Megan le Cheval,
Canard!
They just rap about sexy
things in naughty ways.
But that gives me an idea.
(upbeat music)
All you need to have a
successful hip-hop record,
is to sing about bottoms
and tell dirty jokes...
Mais oui, oui, oui!
♪ Bonjour mon chere, Je m'apelle Pierre ♪
♪ Couldn't help but
stare at your derrière ♪
♪ Soft and round like a Camembert ♪
♪ I went to fill it in
like a questionnaire ♪
♪ I'm french, you can
tell it wiz one glance ♪
♪ Cos I'm smoking this
cigarette, through a croissant ♪
♪ I wear a striped shirt,
smell faintly of garlic ♪
♪ Every woman that I know
doesn't shave her armpits ♪
♪ From Nice to Calais,
Marseilles to Alsace ♪
♪ I wear a beret and pound girls ass ♪
♪ I show you techniques
between my sheets ♪
♪ This is Europe so I kiss
you on both of your cheeks ♪
♪ Like a multiple winner
of the Tour de France ♪
♪ I hop on and ride it more than once ♪
♪ Why eat cake when you
can have my baguette ♪
♪ So gimme that head, Marie Antoinette ♪
♪ Then lift your legs high
like you do the can can ♪
♪ And I'll slap it til it
looks like you got a suntan ♪
♪ I'll be coming on time,
that's a prompt arrival ♪
♪ Like a tower in Paris
prepare for an eyeful ♪
♪ J'adore la derriere ♪
♪ It's my one true love affair ♪
♪ I'm a backside admirer ♪
♪ J'adore la derriere ♪
♪ I like a lady with enough to share ♪
♪ So big that you need two chairs ♪
♪ After me other lovers
are hell, that's Sartre ♪
♪ So swallow don't spit like a llama ♪
♪ Then I'll sow my seed like a farmer ♪
♪ When i give it to you
raw, steak tartare ♪
♪ I'm gonna make you wine
like I'm from bordeaux ♪
♪ When I explore your depths
like Jacques Cousteau ♪
♪ Pop me in your mouth like an escargot ♪
♪ Then it's into your
box, Marcel Marceau ♪
♪ It's long overdue for our rendezvous ♪
♪ I'll give you multiple
orgasms, deja vu ♪
♪ Rump so sweet like a pamplemousse ♪
♪ I'll turn it inside
out like the pompidou ♪
♪ Like napoleon, give you my boney part ♪
♪ Set your loins on
fire like Joan of Arc ♪
♪ Then send me to the
back like Rosa Parks ♪
♪ And i'll dine on the
derriere, a la carte ♪
♪ I like a big booty, a huge caboose ♪
♪ I want to fill it up
like a foie gras goose ♪
♪ Starting out tight but
I'm leaving it loose ♪
♪ In the morning you'll be
needing a cranberry juice ♪
♪ J'adore la derriere ♪
♪ Jaime bein le posterior ♪
♪ I'll sink in my teeth
in like a terrier ♪
♪ J'adore la derriere ♪
♪ And ze general area ♪
♪ To be fair, I'll fuck you anywhere ♪
(coughs)
I'm such a cool Frenchman.